thousands of Gun Owners surrounding the
State Capitol in protest against new gun
control laws it's legal to own and carry
weapons in public in Virginia and most
did in order to show defiance to a
package of new gun control laws working
their way through the Democratic
controlled legislature so he came to
support these folks and to talk to
people and find out what's going on with
them the rally was held amid heavy
security
the governor banned weapons from inside
the Capitol grounds and called a state
of emergency wanting to avoid a replay
of this violence at a 2017 white
nationalist rally in Charlottesville
that killed one person gun violence has
hit close to home in this state recently
last year in Virginia Beach a
disgruntled city employee shot and
killed 12 people organizers of Monday's
rally were eager to give off the
impression they were peaceful
law-abiding gun owners and everybody
outside this fence you can bet your
boots is probably arms well I haven't
heard one shot have you knock on wood
thank goodness I haven't heard one shot
guns aren't a problem there were worries
of potential violence of outsiders and
Tifa and anti-government militia groups
coming from the outside trying to maybe
stoke violence here at this rally but we
have seen absolutely none of that so far
it's been a completely peaceful event
here large numbers of people all of whom
say here that they are out here with
their guns to show that this is their
right and they want to keep that right
and protected gun owners like Bill
garner who brought his assault rifle to
the rally a gun he says he does not use
for hunting you hear all these
candidates and stuff talking about what
do you need a rifle to kill this deer or
this animal it has nothing to do with
that
it's a check on government gun control
advocates canceled their plans for a
counter rally on Monday to avoid
provoking confrontations this was a day
for those who love their guns to show
that they are holding on to them tight
and don't plan to let go
Gabe Rolando al Jazeera Richmond
Virginia